all right let's move on to our five
headlines
[Music]
we're going to go through these
headlines here remember um there's so
much going on in the news if you want to
keep up with all of it
make sure to get a reader's pass at
dailywire.com go to dailywire.com
subscribe today and that will give you
access to all of our
exclusive content uh minus the the
mainstream media leftist spin
get exclusive op-eds from your podcast
hosts as well as guest writers in-depth
analysis from daily wire reporters
um on top of all the regular breaking
news as well the membership tier is
three dollars a month but you can get
your first month for 99 cents so go to
dailywire.com subscribe and join
today okay um
where are we number one a hologram
effigy of
george floyd will be touring the
southern states to be projected onto
confederate monuments in georgia north
carolina
uh virginia other places
floyd's family members are behind this
project and they unveiled it
at a ceremony in richmond i think it was
yesterday
it was projected over a jefferson davis
memorial
the daily news the daily news describes
the hologram this way it says the
hologram starts out with
fireflies that coalesce into a 3d image
of floyd with his name depicted in
graffiti on either side to reflect the
murals
that have sprung up worldwide now
okay i want you to imagine how
traumatizing this must be
legitimately traumatizing for george
floyd's victims
and yes he did have victims
just how how would you feel think about
how you would feel
put yourself in the shoes of his victims
think about the woman
who was robbed at gunpoint by floyd
after he
forced his way into her house held a gun
to her stomach in front of her child
how would she feel how would you feel if
that happened to you
seeing the giant face of your attacker
glowing and projected onto a memorial
like you some kind of
heavenly vision uh this
as as i've been saying for a while now
you know we have gone
of course way way way beyond
just uh expressing outrage over
an unjust death this this is way into
the realm
of canonizing sanctifying
hero worship of a man who was
to put it really mildly not a hero
at all um
[Music]
but this is what we're doing let's go to
number two here's a
a fun story reading from the new york
post it says a suspected arsonist faces
up to 20 years in jail for trying to
torch portland's justice center
and he was and i hope he actually does
all 20 years which which but i think we
know that's not going to happen
uh he was easily identified thanks to a
tattoo of his name on his back according
to prosecutors edward
edward shinzing 32 was one of 30 who
broke into the area that houses the
city's police headquarters
under the cover of protests in late may
the mob attack led to the area later
being secured with heavy gates
after smashing windows the mob spray
painted offices
broke computers and then started a
series of fires in a jail records office
forcing staff to flee for safety
shinzing was
according to the police department
identified by a comparison with a jail
booking photo and a distinctive tattoo
of his last name across his back um
a booking photograph shows his surname
in large letters across his back
seemingly matching those of a topless
intruder caught in security camera
footage
from the attack uh yeah and
unfortunately
for for him his last name is shinzing
like at least if it was smith or johnson
or something like that he could maybe
claim that the guy in the footage is
someone
else someone with his last name who
looks just like him
and also has the same tattoo it's not a
very plausible denial but at least it's
possible
uh it's more possible than claiming that
there's more than one shin zing in the
area
up to mischief i'll never understand
of of all the the dumb tattoos people
get i will never understand getting a
tattoo of your own name
this is a somewhat common thing and i i
just don't get it it's
it's pretty lazy for one thing it seems
as though you went to the tattoo parlor
sat down had no idea what you wanted
and then came up with this on the spot
it's like the tattoo artist
so what do you want um i don't know i
hadn't really thought about it i mean
my name let's just go with that
but of course that's not how tattoos
work you know maybe it works that way in
like prison i don't know but
in the in the free world it's a slower
and more considered process
and yet you settle on your own name and
though
and then you go and commit crimes with
your shirt off
exposing your name antifa
antifa they are not sending their best
uh they really aren't or maybe
this is their best which is a scary
thought
number three the actress uh i think
she's an actress tiffany haddish
appeared on carmella anthony's
carmelo anthony show yesterday come
early anthony of course the basketball
player
apparently has his own show everybody
does these days
they even gave one to me i mean it's
pretty easy to get one
and during the discussion at one point
she explained why she doesn't want to
bring
kids into this world and speaking of
being paranoid uh listen to this
i'm not a fearful person right but like
i have watched many of my friends not
many but
more than two of my friends growing up
be killed by police officers
you know and and it makes you feel like
dang
you know as a black person we were being
hunted
and like i felt like and i've always
felt like that we're hunted and we're
slaughtered
and it's like they get this license to
kill us and that's not okay
and you know i'm i'm older now
a little older and people are like
you're gonna have baby when you're gonna
have some babies when you're gonna drop
some babies and
and there's a part of me that would
would like to do that and always make up
these excuses like oh i need a million
dollars in the bank before i can touch
you i need this i need that
but really it's like i would hate to
give birth to someone that looks like me
and then knowing that they're going to
be hunted or killed
you know like why would i put someone
through that look i know it doesn't
matter at this point
uh nope nobody nobody cares it we're way
past the point
when things like facts make a difference
to anyone
but for the record this police are
hunting
people down thing is completely and
totally untrue
um not even a little true there is
literally zero truth to it it never
happens
so when someone says police are hunting
and killing uh black people
it's not just that they're exaggerating
it's that they're inventing something
that never happens
certainly not in recent history unless i
mean prove me wrong
give me an example give me an example if
you have one of police going out and
hunting and killing a black person
um now there are cases of people of
police killing people obviously
in the vast majority of those cases the
people who are killed were in the
process of trying to kill officers
that's true as as we have gone over even
of the unarmed killings
in most of those cases uh the the the
the person was trying to kill
officers either by using a uh a weapon
that doesn't count as a weapon in the
official reports like a vehicle
or by trying to disarm them and take
their weapon and use it against them
that sort of thing
and in the very very very very small
minority of
of actual unjust killings
none of them that i've ever heard of
could be honestly described as police
hunting and killing someone you want to
say that george floyd killing was unjust
fine if you say that that the man was
hunted and killed then you're just a
dishonest ridiculous hack
and i think you know that um
number four the daily beast has a report
now about the insane backlash
a music review for the site pitchfork
phase
the reviewer named uh jillian mapes um
and mapes wrote a positive but mildly
critical review of taylor swift's new
album
folklore i think it's called and because
it wasn't positive enough
swift's fans harassed her actually doxed
her according to the daily beast
posted her address and her phone number
um doxed her because she didn't like
taylor swift's album
enough she liked it but didn't like it
enough
you know she gave whatever b minus or
something whatever her grade was and it
wasn't an a
plus you know it's not good enough this
is why
of all the lost souls of all the
deranged groups of people in america and
there are many of them
none are more lost or more deranged than
people who find their their identity
in their fandom you know whether they're
fans of a pop star or a movie like star
wars or a tv show or video games
whatever it is
um there's nothing wrong with being a
fan okay i'm a fan believe it or not
there are there are things and people
that i like
if you can believe it not many but there
are some what i'm talking about is
finding your identity
in your fandom if that's like the most
important thing
to you in your life for that to be
basically
the number one thing about you the most
prominent component of your life
is that you're a fan of this thing or
this person
uh if you fall into that category then
you are no offense
the most pathetic sort of person that
it's possible to be
the phrase get a life was invented for
you specifically
um and here's how to know that you're in
that group okay maybe maybe maybe you're
not sure if you're if you're that far
into it
um here's how to know you're in that
group or you're you're headed in that
direction you're
nearly in that group if you get angry
actually truly angry when someone
doesn't like a form of entertainment
that you like
you know if you are incapable of having
a discussion with someone
who is critical of your favorite thing
or who doesn't like as much as you
if you cannot engage with any critical
discussion of this thing or person that
you like
because you become blind with fury and
start to feel real hatred towards that
person
that's a good sign that you are way way
too invested
in this thing whatever it is and yes
that goes for sports teams too i will
throw that in
not gonna leave that out and i say that
as someone who sometimes teeters close
to the edge of being a pathetic loser in
this regard i admit that
i do take my fandom of the baltimore
ravens
quite seriously too seriously in fact
and um
and so yes i am kind of a pathetic loser
there but but the saving grace is that
it only lasts for four months out of the
year
uh so for four months of the year i'm a
pathetic dork
when it comes to the you know my
football fandom but then i revert back
to being normal again for
for the rest of it so it's only a third
of the year okay for me
being pathetic it's not too bad it's not
great but
it's it's not as bad as it could be but
even as seriously as i take sports
you know i still don't take it as
seriously as some people do
you know i've seen a not unfamiliar site
people get into fist
fights i mean many of us have seen this
if you're at a
stadium or a sportswear i was at a
sports bar a little while ago
and two dudes in different team jerseys
got into a fight
now granted there was alcohol involved
okay but but even so
um i've never been tempted to punch
someone because they liked a different
team than me
think about what that is okay you're
you're trying to cause physical harm to
someone
because they like to watch a different
group of men play a game
oh yeah this group of men are better at
playing
the game than than your favorite group
no they're not
no this group is even better you bastard
i'll kill you i mean it's just
it's it's not stable is all i'm saying
it really doesn't stop and think about
what you're doing
every once in a while um okay number
five this is this is good to report from
the new york post
um says let me read a little bit it says
there's some real monkey business at a
british safari park where a roving gang
of baboons
armed with knives and even a chainsaw
have been wreaking havoc and sowing fear
according to a report
the prowling primates are known to have
vandalized vehicles
uh ripping off windshield wipers and
mirrors from them
at the knolls noseley safari park
uh but the baboons now i'm
just reading through here
oh this is disappointing i should have
read this before
now park officials are saying that it's
uh it's a myth
the park told the news outlet we believe
many of these stories have grown in
exaggeration as they've been retold with
embellishment to make the objects that
are
sometimes found in the enclosure seem
more exciting and unbelievable ah that's
disappointing
this is what i get for just going with
the headline usually i try to do better
than that usually i try to you know i
i i try not to be one of those people
that just
sees a headline and i'm off to the races
but when the headline is
chainsaw wielding baboons i'm going with
the headline
okay because and this is exactly why
then you read the details
and it's it's depressing because it
turns out maybe that's not actually the
case
i i like the idea though okay this is
what i want to say this is good because
i think we can all agree right that it's
it's probably time to wrap up this whole
humanity deal
like i think we've all it's it's we've
we've all seen enough
we've really run our course and milked
it for what it's worth and uh
it's probably time to just you know get
on with it get on with the apocalypse
one way or another
so it's just a matter now choosing the
best apocalypse okay how do we want to
finally self-destruct and a planet of
the apes type of thing could be a lot of
fun
now if i had my pick of the of the
litter i would still go with the alien
invasion but
if that's not gonna happen if my dreams
are dashed um
then i think yeah arm the baboons maybe
do a little genetic
manipulation type of thing like they do
in the movies and just let them go to
work
um not a bad way for the human species
to
go out i think you have to admit so
those are our five headlines
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
like and then subscribe to our youtube
channel so you don't miss out on any of
our content